hbo max just dropped the highly
anticipated sex and the city revival and
just like that and spoiler alert they
just killed off one of the main
characters so this is your official
warning if you haven't watched yet
and just like that
they died
what was the most challenging aspect of
getting this band this creative team
back together again uh to align everyone
to understand that we were doing
the show that we used to do but knew and
to discover what was new about it rather
than what was
left over the beloved franchise returned
as a revival series thursday on hbo max
following carrie bradshaw miranda hobbs
and charlotte york enjoying life in
their 50s and embracing their new gray
hair
we can't just stay who we were
right absolutely and there are more
important issues in the world than
trying to look young figuring out you
know who carrie is who is charlotte who
is miranda
putting that back together is
probably not quite as simple as some
might think because
you may recall how they sound and walk
and talk but more so who are they now
and what has time given them and
how do you reveal that and what do they
dress like and what matters to them
but at the end of the first episode
kerry's husband mr bigg goes to take a
shower after cycling at home and drops
his phone before grabbing his left
shoulder and when carrie returns home
she finds him and breaks down in tears
[Music]
and just like that
they died
e.t spoke to chris noth who plays mr big
at the new york city premiere on
wednesday night and he admitted at first
he didn't immediately sign on for the
revival i just
love all the people involved in it and
um
i was a little hesitant at first you
know because well it's
interesting that it
like this whole thing there's
so much attention garnered on it you
know it becomes a little um
intimidating sometimes for you chris
private life
really
but um you know
hey mr big
you're always going to be big to so many
people yeah i can't seem to shake it but
hey that's decided not to
in the show's second episode little
black dress which also premiered on
thursday it's confirmed big suffered a
heart attack
what do i do now
i guess
they
take him away
and no women me
what do i do now
the women take turns spending the night
with carrie and even samantha whose
absence from the show is explained by a
falling out with carrie in the first
episode sends a stunning floral
arrangement to biggs funeral
who's it even from
they can stay
but prior to his death the show gave
fans a taste of big's happy life with
carrie
[Music]
is that supposed to make me forget that
you're a half hour late and there may be
some flashback or dream montages with mr
big in future episodes given that chris
was spotted filming all over new york
city and the only on-screen moments
shown so far take place inside the
couple's apartment
[Music]